hello everybody and welcome to part 21
of let's play penumbra overture we're
about to cut these wires and see what
happens what what happens oh yeah all in
one stroke oh so great oh yeah
huh beat it dog yeah oh yeah okay what
do we got here what do we got here
come on lever crowbar boink
oh yeah as I stepped into the mouth of
the underground facility this should
have been questions
Oh my nameís oh hello boink the shelter
all this is not gonna be good this is
where the monsters are uh-huh uh-huh
dead dead uh dead uh oh boy this isn't
gonna be good not gonna be good was
Billy like the watchman for all these
monsters all right
oh I remember you from waivable bunk I'm
not gonna open fine what are you alright
Oh exit yeah excellent
most excellent oh hello
come in come on open up open up
nope I'm gonna open is it another one of
those touchier things no it's nothing
it's nothing
hi who are you oh the hell are you
Oh bring it on Oh bring it bring it
I'll get you I'll get you ah ah hey hi
oh come on
what the hell was that was he supposed
to run after me I have no idea I showed
him yeah yeah whatever
okay Pippi can oh that's the end okay
now yeah yeah I'm so great actually
what I'm gonna do is want to see if he
actually was gonna run after me and
maybe that would have been scary I have
no idea okay so let me just load up a
game here
ah that seems to be the most recent all
right let's see what happens if it's
scary I'll act scared oh yeah this place
okay all right and then I open this it's
like oh oh noes oh oh it's a toilet oh
why is yeah oh I'm not gonna talk about
that oh yeah all the way that's C all
right
and then oh oh wait I gotta cut in here
look thanks for watching see ya part 21
okay
boink hello now yeah all right and then
oh I mean oh I gotta cut it here huh Oh
in one fell swoop
oh I'm so strong and awesome and
handsome Oh get out here dog okay okay
all right all right
ha crowbar funk as I 70 bit the mouth of
Underground's with it I'll [ __ ] it okay
oh no oh oh oh no there's why the
monsters are dead dead dead
uh have you all know this is where all
the monster was he like a watchman for
the monsters all right oh yeah I
remember you from for long I'm not gonna
open how about you come on oh nothing oh
nothing
whole lotta nothin oh wait oh no oh you
oh what's going on open on Arcana Oh
who's that I'll [ __ ] you I'm waiting for
you this time bring it on Oh bring it
bring it on
you got nothing you got nothing nothing
at all
oh no I'm George dear oh let me go it's
time shut I know what's going on
ah we're gonna hang out here get me out
there
Oh Oh whatever what about this door oh
no I'm so scared
oh you go you're gonna die in the face
ah ah hey hey oh oh I bet that killed
you alright I guess I was it okay I'm
pretty good
it was way different way way different
from amnesia I mean given that this was
frictional games first try at a game I
think this was their very first one it
was still very good the atmosphere was
there I mean the graphics weren't nearly
on par with amnesia but still I could
tell for a 2007 game the graphics were
okay on the interaction was a little
sketchy but and there weren't as many
scares as I wanted there to be but I
guess I went for a more creepy
atmosphere but from what I've heard the
next few episodes are scarier so I'm
gonna get right on those um and thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed it I had fun playing it I had
fun recording it and I hope I didn't
seem too big of an idiot because some of
those puzzles were a lot easier than I
made them out to be honestly I should
have gotten to a man I oppose
also my first few videos way too dark
sorry about that I didn't even think
about using my flashlight next time I'll
be sure to always use my flashlight or
glow stick and so that you guys can see
but once again thank you so much for
watching and I will see you and let's
play penumbra the Black Plague I think
it's called at the best of excellence
alright just wait now credits I don't
have any more cool stories to tell you
yep yep that's it obviously I was way
too badass for this game but that's how
it goes
I will see you guys later bye bye